okay four people joining our live stream
this is a discussion about some aspects
of our new database integration
framework so what are we talking about
here
relations okay so it's actually mmm
relations sound complicated but on the
surface they're very simple that we're
we're saying so with respect to the
other stuff we've talked about this is a
new and different thing that we have not
discussed is that correct we have seen
it but we've not discussed it in detail
okay all right so yeah in the in the
surface this is very simple
mmm because relations are just basically
entity valued properties and it already
value properties okay yes or entity
class valued property and the problem is
really when you're looking at the SQL
database they don't really have this con
I mean they can't store expressions so
they can store entities but they have a
concept that mats quite closely that's
the concept of foreign key okay so
following that property using entity
values so
you
okay so what are you trying to do here
so basically this is the lazy
representation and if you try to
evaluate and see value Newhaven people
born in city you will get a list of I
don't know 100 I tried it and then I
gave up a while because it was taking
long well but why is that that's because
our I mean maybe we should try it with a
smaller city
okay I don't know why that gave a date
as well for that property but that
doesn't really matter but okay so that
works yeah
so you're saying here
and so this would have to go entity list
yeah okay but by saying that you'd like
you go into list you're giving a pretty
opinionated version of what the person
should do with it is maybe you don't
care about what the entity list is you
care you wanted to snow and it's done
that I understand that so that but
you're saying find things of entity
class person so in this case your pre
specifying what the type of the response
will be yes I mean in a sense the the
transformation from people born in
cities with that entity class doesn't
read need to talk to a database to
happen because it's like just a
transformation of that you need to know
the relation so long as you know the
type relations yeah but it might not be
the case that I mean there may not be a
uniform type to the entity value of some
particular property oh yeah that is
there have to be there has to be a
uniform - exactly
yeah okay but in general in this
formulation that doesn't have to be a
uniform type no okay so I understand
what you're saying here so now what so
in general for databases will represent
this type of Reavers relations as entity
classes because it's a lot more
efficient in terms of speed and because
you can chain it and and chaining is
very powerful because most of the times
you can avoid is basically making a
pitch for why we should be documenting
the no that's cool um that's pretty cool
that that worked
okay
I know why this happened do we know what
that is
that's probably a new bug in the version
12 whoever who is project managing here
okay so what are you trying to argue
here I mean you're trying to argue that
when we're doing this for the food
databases that I I don't even know how
you would get this version because we
don't do we have a thing like entities
yes we could get entities out of
I'll out incredible right we do already
we do already where because basically
the entity becomes kind of the headdress
around the foreign key okay well fine
but I mean so you're simply proposing
that the primary thing we document is
this entity class mechanism I mean it
depends basically entity single entity
would mean this is guaranteed to be a
many to one relation and so I don't know
something like persons a person can only
be part of one department in a company
and and so if in the database its coded
as a foreign key then you can't have
multiple answers to that question
yeah can be missing but it can't be
multiple things on the other hand all
the things that are gotten out of the
database as reverse or foreign keys can
in full generality be lists of things so
what I mean the database is what it is
the only question is how we tell people
to access that correct
yeah yeah okay so the answer is you
propose to document this way of
accessing it and not document or at
least not emphasize this way of access
it's not about what we document is
basically you if you if you scroll down
if you look at the workflow basically I
explain how we extract these things from
database and turn them into user
friendly things so this last how is
relations current specified turns out
that in the database the way they are
stored is by just saying that they have
a two table from columns and two columns
what are we talking about here what what
is the issue what is the question what
is the issue these shoes how do these
things get specified in the entity store
in the end sorry if you want to go from
data which is just integers and strings
and you want to go to something that
returns actual entities and entity
classes as values you need to be able to
specify these things but but but I don't
understand the the database has what it
has in it it has things pointing to
foreign keys for example so are you
saying that in the description of
the entity store we have to give
metadata that describes what those got
foreign correspondent we don't have to
because the the default creation will
discover the foreign keys and create
relate the most basic relations from
them but we need to document how they
get specified automatically in case
people want to add more for example so
if you scroll down is this a proposed
design change or is it no it's not a
design change is that the first time I
showed you this you said you weren't
happy with it so I'm trying to motivate
why we if you scroll up a little bit I
don't understand how using entity
classes helps a lot with the chaining it
that helps you go one level further this
not only you can also apply queries to
that class Tony and if it will be a list
then means that you kind of leave the
database world but the point is that
it's test can be chained almost
indefinitely if you want to but still
you get an array of deeper and deeper
depth no it's only true if you think
about this in the list birding but for
us it's getting flattened so you chain
transforms on those entity classes no
but you are right and I say almost
indefinitely because if you keep if you
follow multiple times want many
relations you might get in trouble if
you don't aggregate them so for example
in that case where I was comparing the
mean to something else it was because I
needed to aggregate hold ah can I run
this no how would I runners I mean the
syntax is wrong maybe and because the
syntax has not yet been updated so ok
but I mean this particular thing so this
is a property value of property property
property property all chained right yeah
and I mean I mean I guess this would
break at some point because they all
return lists and so you can chain them
like that because lists don't have some
values no this will never work with this
that's why we at the beginning we had
thought to introduce into the property
path but so what I was saying to Tony is
that if you look at that mean that mean
I'm using because otherwise the
cardinality of what you get there from
on the left-hand side of the grater is
different from the cardinality of what
you gets on the right-hand side and this
would fail so sometimes you yes you need
to aggregate as well as as branch
I I don't understand what the point is I
don't understand what they okay let's
get to what what is it is this some okay
what's this
so now this SQL database object has a
table person and that TV has including
tricksters yes it is we already met with
Belize just not yet in your build okay
okay so basically the person table has
some that information attached to it
that this foreign key constraints and
they have this pretty hard to read form
where basically you have to that point
to person itself and their friend an
enemy and then you have one that points
nation and the two columns are all
called ID because they point to the
primary key and private key has called
ID in old stables
so we've condensed this information into
basically the same syntax as merged as
the third argument of merged entity
class because that's what it is
it's a SQL join I completely don't
understand what the point is can we zoom
out for a minute sure would you tell me
tell me what the point is starting from
the beginning okay the point is that we
want to have properties that return
entities also on databases I get it
there is an auto discovery mechanism and
we need to somehow document the syntax
oh wait a second the order discovery
says this thing is going to be to a
foreign key that foreign key points to
some other weird echo here that foreign
key points to another day another
database right table table in the
database Andy you need to consider also
the fact that each time you have a
foreign key you also have a reverse
relation and there is an automatic
naming mechanism that we invented but
but yeah did this is what
the table the the table to which the
foreign key points yes is also
associated with an entity with some
registered entity type in the entity
store is that correct yes
okay so we're discovering our head yeah
so that becomes the to type it goes to
an entity type yeah I understand okay so
far so for example if you scroll down a
little bit then you look at that entity
store you have a property that's not
underlined that's coordination the last
one yes yeah and then you have one that
is underlined that has a little arrow
that is nation relation so nation is the
native one and that we returned just a
string that's the ID of the nation
nation relation actually returns an
entity
so hold on hold on hold on so you're
saying this thing points to you're
saying this thing is simply the string
name in the nation table is that right
whereas this is some kind of entity
representation in the nation table is
that correct yes oh if you're going to
the nation table so opening that other
flipper there you will see that there is
also reverse relation that is person
from nation okay I don't care
I'm just trying to understand this right
now okay so
this is a value if I'm understanding
correctly this is
when you say types here this is a value
for of one of these person fields is
that right
yeah what value honor of one of those
properties yes
right okay and so that type is called
nation and that nation type is actually
really should be called nation name
I think no but that's that's nation name
is a logical initial name is a native
name in the database so I've been trying
as as much as I can not to rename the
things that are already into database so
it's not the same database right it's in
a different database
no it's in the same database label no
cysteine nation there is the name of a
column in the same table it turns out to
be also okay fine so that which also
happens to be the name of another
database is that another table right now
there are tables in the same database
okay fine
but then that other table
so that's the column name but this says
types here right is it a type or is it a
column name now that if when it's not
open those are types nation person and
transaction are the types then you can
flip burn each type has columns or
properties rather I'm sorry
the type or is this a column in the
original dated top-level flippers are
types no they're not wait a minute the
top-level flippers so its initial
person's right says types : is utterly
confusing
right it should be up here
that's that's the default of the I mean
I can change it but it's no no but I
mean I don't understand what this is
so that
that's super confusing the way that
looks
right yeah so I I don't know that's a
graphic design issue Andrea that's for
you please I don't know what this means
here is that why is that what is that
that's just a but I mean don't this is
that that is already change don't even
look at that okay okay okay fine
all right okay so that's a type
okay
so this here is a column of the person
table right yes
what's this that's that's basically I
mean the reason there is that is because
the property extractor could be you
could be renaming something so it's not
necessary what is that what is that
right hand side what is that thing that
but it can be an entity function can be
an entity property or it can be in the
case of relational Association
you
okay so this here so this is the pure
column nation is that correct yes okay
so this is something which is telling
you for the entries in the column if I'm
not mistaken
something about what what they map to is
that correct no this I mean imagine you
have a person entity if you ask for the
property nation you'd get a string if
you ask for the property nation relation
you get basically the same string
addressed with an entity I understand
that's what I was trying to say
why does it not say that this is a
string well is there nothing here that
says that the type of this output for
nation is a string we could add that I
mean that information is currently only
encoded in the SQL database object and
we don't bubble it up to the entity
level to me to know what it is what what
you know this thing this entity property
basically what is the contents of the
nation column here I don't even know
property type is saying what property
type of that is so this is a column
right
tractor is the extractor you would use
from this type here to get to an entry
in that column is that correct no not
quite the property extractor is
basically it's like it's adding a level
of indirection so if you decide to call
nation country the property extractor
would still say nation there but the the
flipper the king the flipper would say
country so this is a way in which you
can rename the columns I'm sorry I don't
understand it's the thing that I said
correct no okay tell me why not
okay because the in this case nation
points to nation we haven't done any
renaming this is the default constructor
yeah and if you were to rename nation to
country the property extractor would
still say nation but the name of the
property would be what is this full
thing what is that thing there what is
it what is that
enter Internet is that an entity
property object yes it's an amusing
ization for any property reading then
don't abuse it please don't abuse it
it's already confusing enough as it is
but I don't wait to specify to specify
on save
the prefix otherwise what prefix the
entity type prefix yes okay what is the
entity type prefix here I mean in this
case what is the entity type prefix in
this case in this case is just person so
it's trivial it's not trivial it's it's
okay so here's what I think whatever
happens here this display should make it
clear that there is a identity type
prefix on what that entity type prefix
is I'm making sense
and I don't think that this is the right
thing to this is using that that's
nonsense
I mean if I might say so this is
in what sense is that a property type
column
that means that it's native so it can be
either column or relation or function so
it's either natively a column or it can
be a relation it can be something that
is computed so and it's function so what
are the other possibilities for that
column relation function okay that's not
using the word type in the same sense
that we use type
okay why would you change it to I don't
know but it's not it's super confusing
because type is a different thing here
it's not an entity type type
you
Ricardo or Lynyrd anybody have any other
suggestions this is clearly not a type
so it cannot be called the type
yeah but we need some way to distinguish
between different sorts of fields that
we'll have here because they have
different origin incense different yeah
I understand
so some of them come from the original I
know we just talked about we just talked
about what they are right but we can't
call that property type because that's a
completely different thing isn't it
I mean property type would be string in
this case so yeah that's right that's
what it should be that's what it should
be what about property kind
first your origin that's much better
that's much better a property source
properties source property
the property origin is good start
or properly what is it it's how you
compute that property
yeah what kind of valleys we are right
now we have column we can be also
function right
there also be property Genesius or
something that is it the z4 also for
relation we got the same so something
like many to one or something is still
inside the same key over to origin or is
different thing I think it's different
this just says that the column is either
present originally or computed so but
even if you click on person friend and
you expand it to our property like that
as well
what does relation mean
means that it's generated from the
relations that are in the schema of this
database so it's generated property of a
special kind we've got to be clear on
what's going on here so look if what
this says so first point is this thing
whatever it is has got to be let's say
its property origin
okay um
I'm thinking column
but but are we sure we want origin with
all the mathematical meaning of it I
don't know but type is not going to cut
it so we're are not provenance and
source is better what source
you
well actually look
that will be a better thing to call it
if we're really going to try and call it
something where it explains what it is
you
well that would be the extractor really
property values force why is that the
extractor tire yes why is that the
extractor because it's telling you what
column to get it from
no I think the the meaning that Stephen
put into this was different it was
basically the the origin of from where
does it come from not which calm does it
come from right
I mean very long but this adding
we have property source type and
property source instead of property
extractor robbery source type would be
column and property source would be I
don't think it should be called property
suppose I think it should be called this
one should be called property source and
then
[Music]
what is it isn't it extractor what what
is that thing this thing here what do
you use that for I mean so if it's a
function that would be an entity
function but what is it in this case
with the relation how do you use the
situation that I need to construct the
relation so it's how do you use this how
do you use this okay it's closely
related to merged and how do you
specifically use this what function do
you put it generate we generate entity
function from this spec why don't you
give the entity function because the
entity function we generate might be
different in different contexts so it's
better to keep it and this is actually
simpler to reason about because in some
cases you might want to turn this into a
sub-query in some cases in for join but
the specification is the same look what
I would do here is this I would have
this thing be simply a thing called
property source and then I would have
that be an association which has all the
detail you want
then I would say column name
etc
it's really if it is a string we can say
there is a column if it is a dollar base
function of course is created and if it
isn't a suggestion is the whole thing
even that's that's what we do it no no
wait but I'm suggesting that you get rid
of this you have a single thing here
called property source that property
source is an association and all
anything you want still you're not
solving the problem you're just pushing
it off level down no the problem is what
are the keys of that Association
Kuwait's Association that that thing
that you see when you open the flipper
in the input forum is already an
association okay
property type all right so then properly
saw striped column and then the keys
that you give here will be different
depending on what that property sought
source type was
because property extractor makes no
sense makes no sense this thing is
different in different cases it means a
different thing depending on what the
property source type was yes so that's
bad
right that just name it whatever it's
called like like in this case it would
be column name Oh body type is not
present in the Association I inferred
from what's in the property extractor I
don't care it doesn't matter I mean it
will be so then it will be column name
in this case where it's a column it
would give column name where it's
something else it gives another thing
okay what I'm saying so in other words
it's not a fixed Association
okay
but still what are the keys of
disassociation in different cases well I
don't know you have to tell me but I
mean I think you could break this one
apart one way would be to just say that
there are just two types of columns one
is native type and the other is
non-native type and for non-native types
you can have extra things that seems
reasonable the distinction between
relation and yeah but you can keep that
distinction within non-native types well
I don't know whether it matters so
you're saying column function what's the
other one relation but why don't we give
these names look why don't we try giving
these properties sourcetype native
column what's this
what do we call the function thing in
the case of an entity store it's called
the computed property isn't it
that right and have a default function
property
okay so we call the function then
okay what's what about this one is this
one foreign key or what
what is that one what is relation what
does it mean
hello
hello can hear me
I mean who are you asking the question
to any of you I don't know you Nicias
don't really exist all right so what is
this correctly called what should it be
called
but I'm suggesting if it's native column
then in the case of native column right
wait wait native column has a column
named property
if it is function then what does it have
what's the other thing that that's in
that if it's a function oh it has the
function itself
it's an ansi function doesn't need
anything else okay so then it's just
function okay that's the name of that
those are string names for the property
source type the property source type I
don't store it I don't care whether you
store the don't store it doesn't make
any difference so these things I don't
care it doesn't matter right so you can
put this into an association and you
look at the Association you decide from
that Association what you put for the
property source type doesn't make any
difference how you get it
make sense
okay by the way the native column the
company might not be enough yeah well
what do you want to cook or what you
want to do that so the problem is that
just tell me what other what other key
you need in addition let me explain so
the problem is that a tithe can be a
computed type okay so it could be you
could register entity extend sorry
extended entity class or something in
that case it would not be enough say
just the column name you also need the
the the prefix part of the entity
property so it really works like an
entity property that's why I use an
entity property but it but it isn't an
entity property is it
you
it is an instant probably don't use it
if it isn't one just look if you insist
on doing that say have a thing called
column prefix or something and then
column name
all right so let's talk about relation
for a minute please
so I have no idea what this means
that thing is the same thing as the as
the joint condition so it's the same
thing what is it the word to type how
does that get used
so the to type is what will you will get
in the first argument of the entity or
entity class okay I don't think it's a
very good name for it can we can we say
what it really is please
it's an anytime that's your point
okay so let's call it destination entity
type is that right
yes okay all right
next plane the other thing is
effectively the third argument of merge
10th class so it is a condition because
it can be an identity function so well
why don't we call it merging condition I
don't think that's the right thing but
some qualifier for condition
kind of a condition is it
a condition is it it's it's a thing that
is
well you tell me what's this ID thing
here so ID is the column in the in the
right so in the destination type that
you're pointing to and friend is in the
front type the source type okay
first okay person okay so then we'll
call it something instead of coolant
condition
that's the
that's the mapping from entity types
that's basically the entity type mapping
is that right
so basically the friend goes to I D
becomes entity function X Y X friend
equal equal X Y a B just like in merged
entity class so in this most general
form its function yeah well then give it
a function if it needs to be a function
I mean I don't know it's time you
of that okay
look if this is a mapping give it as a
mapping if it's something which is a
function so say you know maybe entity
type mapping function that makes sense
okay it's just the mapping give the
mapping don't try and shoehorn two
different things together
see what I'm saying okay and why is this
analyst here
because the principal there could be
more okay fine just like enjoying cross
or mappings plural no I think I'm opting
can be a list of rules okay all right
so it's just like this is stuff that you
want in the output form or also in the
input one I think in the input form I
would think that's the structure that
you put in here I don't know I mean I'm
trying to make this so it isn't cut
early and comprehensible and I don't
know what this nation - relation is
supposed to be that that's putting the
name of what's going on here
so I mean I can't call you nation
because nation is already I know but
what is this from and to thing here
Froemming - is the is the the property
you derive that from so there is an
original Froemming tool and you know
that their foreign keys and you're
repeating stuff that's it the
information that's given here in the
name is that right yeah is this a name
that's a real name or is this a name
it's just for display no this is a real
name when you get one to get it out to
use that with the dash in it you put
something else but in general there
there will be lowercase so well this is
an appended name appended to
I'm just totally confused this was not
this is not I I can't be helpful to you
here I mean I don't understand enough
about this stuff
I don't know tell me what this is at all
I have no idea what this is so that that
one is if you have a person friend so in
the in this case since friend points to
person itself then you have you have the
friend and you are you have the people
your friend off so this is a convention
that you're doing this - relation thing
or this is something that's being
generated this is a convention that I
made up okay all right fine
okay that's fine
all right well okay fair enough I mean I
could change relation to entity or
entity class but then I would need to
know whether it's going to be an integer
class
so you could say other people think
you
really greatest name this is supposed to
tell you that this is nation as an
entity right yes I may be nationality
dance better
yeah okay but I noticed found person -
enemy what's that supposed to mean
so that's so you you're you have a
property enemy and that's just gonna be
a string or need to turn in this case I
think and so that's the the it's the
personal entity valued version of enemy
foreign key personal entity valued I
don't understand that so okay if you
just get an enemy out you will get an
integer okay
so this is the wrong way around so the
person - look look what you've got is
you've got person - enemy right means
should really be
anime
as person in some sense right whereas
another one your nation relation
should be nation that should be nation
as nation okay let's entertain like that
but why isn't enemy an to them
well maybe it is that it's that really
what that is there why does it love why
does it have to say person because
that's the entities type I mean do you
need to know the entity type at this
stage I mean if you look at so if you
know do you need to know the entity type
I think it's helpful in it and it's the
convention we're following so that's if
there is no collision that's the default
I would just call it person but since
person has a bunch of collisions I
cannot call it personal so in the hazel
that's right I think you should just
call it entity here I mean in the case
of country for example so sorry city
city as a property that's just called
country because it's obvious that the
city can only have one foreign I think
one way you are adding the name of the
type that that might be okay to do
another way will be to just append
entity relaxing and suggesting so if you
have like a column that is called nation
and then you have nation - entity in the
very simple case now we like the case
where there are multiple columns
referring to the same guy and third at
least here will be fixed as well because
here you have like I mean this is a very
pathological case because we have other
examples in which the name of the
probability for example let's say you
have a title type and in the title type
you will have title ID that's its own
primary key and when you have a foreign
key proffered that's just going to be
called author ID and so in that case you
can just call it author when you have an
author
well you gotta just make everyone happy
you know I think I mean
listen let me just suggest this as the
end result okay that you've got either
the thing that's just nation which is
the naked version of what's in the
database right strings for example
yeah so nation you will keep it as it is
yeah
right now if you really want to get it
as a foreign as you know in directing
through this foreign key to another
table then call it - and today
yeah Bank nation the nation table is
much less pathological the destination
table doesn't have foreign keys so it
has only reverse relations in that case
I can just say person the nation has a
relation to person and I can call it
person just like in in in city I called
the relation to country country know
you've got an underline right that
underlined represents something special
it's got an actual name yeah also what
this name is not reflecting car law is
that on the way back it's it's returning
really a list of things and I really
think the name should reflect that so we
should have a person's personality
released or transaction ID released or
something no it's not a class not a
naturalist and through us then but you
know maybe we should reflect the fact
that you know the reverse relation is
returning a list not really single
entity I can do that alright so there
will be person entity class there so
with all of these then be nation entity
class
is that right no that so from person to
nation it's a foreign key so it's an
entity not an auntie class and its from
nation to person that it's in want many
Androids it has reacted
which one so this nation - entity thing
what should that be is an ant no
relation that - entity is correct
it's a person from nation that it's
different okay so fine so then one is
entity and the other is entity clause
make sense okay and what what about when
you need to specify what key you're
using like friend enemy is that what key
using where so like so person has
preferring his to itself so would that
be enemy person entity and friend person
entity I'm totally confused you're
saying that you have to potentially say
what the table that you're going to is
so the know what the format is the
native column name - the table name
destination table name
- the dressing right yes right right now
if if there is only one that is going to
the table I omit the the native column
name because that's I only use that to
disambiguate so for example you
otherwise it would be nation nation
entity but there's only one alright okay
so the question is whether a friend
person entity an enemy personal entity
or not I would use the column name
rather than the table name
there isn't always a column name yeah
it's probably not always right but in
any case it is not always going to be
right okay but this is a convention so
what do you suggest in ricotta I think
that in most cases people really use the
column name as the name of the table
like it's obvious that if you have up a
table days country probably the corner
isn't very stable it's on which country
but if you're using a different name
probably is because this name means
something so I will use in the reverse
relation the relevant name instead of
the table name is right so you're saying
omit the table name
I would omit the table name yes and what
the column name that's but again those
are my five cents yeah okay I mean an F
for this ambigú a shin you need to give
the table name then give it I still
think that in simple cases the table
name is way more informative okay you
guys go you guys go figure this out okay
okay all right so is there anything else
not in this but we need to start
documentation I'm not working on that I
you guys need to work on that who's
going to help you with that I mean I
already started the stop sign I thought
you wanted to go through at ease the
usage messages I will want to go through
them all yes but I think you should go
through them with somebody else first
okay who have you guys worked with in
the past for documentation have you done
a bunch yourself I can't remember yeah I
did interpreter for function oh yeah you
know how to do this color you know yeah
usage messages then the examples we do
ourselves yeah okay well so get
candidate usage messages okay but I do
like format and so okay great okay well
set up another meeting for that it's
going to be difficult in terms of timing
but but go ahead and try and get
something set up
okay all right for those on the
livestream I think we have another
meeting about synthetic geometry that's
just coming out okay see y'all soon